My day job is publishing skeptic magazine and directing the skeptic society,
which is a five Oh one C3 non-profit science education organization.
I got interested in the topics,
which is pretty much any of the super interesting topics related to science and
religion and spirituality and cults and free will and determinism and God,
you know,
pretty much all the great topics I'm interested in really goes back to being in
college. And I was a born again, Christian.
I'm, Dave Rubin, and this is the Rubin report reminder, everybody,
you can get all our videos and audio podcasts, absolutely add free and
early@rubinreport.com.
And joining me today is the publisher of skeptic magazine host of the science
salon podcast and author of the new book,
giving the devil his due Michael Shermer. Welcome back to the Rubin report.
Good to be back. The tournament of champions continues.
We've had a couple of technical difficulties today to make this thing happen.
But here we are. I know that as a man of faith,
you're going to pray that our connection does.
Uh, I I'm praying away. I'm not going to try to pray away the gay for you,
but I'm gonna try to pray away.
The Corona virus plugs in our computer systems here. It's the 5g you see?
Oh, it's definitely, it's definitely the 5g it's coming for everybody.
It's spreading coronavirus, coronavirus and the rest of it. All right. There,
there's a ton I want to get to here because I really love this book.
And I just said to you right before we started that so much in,
in my book as well, we really covered the topics,
but come to slightly different conclusions on a couple of things.
And the way we approach the topics is a little bit different each time.
But before we get to the book itself, you've written 16 books.
And as a guy that just wrote one and knows what it takes to write one,
how do you possibly not only come up with enough material,
but enough sort of personal fortitude and patience and,
and all of it to just be able to sit there and put all of those thoughts out
16 times and quite successfully, by the way,
it's not like nobody's reading these things.
Yeah. Well, thank you. I appreciate that. Well, first of all, I'm 65.
So I've got a couple of decades on your almost, uh, just cumulative time.
But I also started riding in my twenties when I was in college.
I actually always wanted to be a writer.
And then by the time I got to my early thirties,
I had written quite a bit that wasn't published, just, you know,
just practicing stuff and trying to get things published,
such that by my first book, uh, let's see, in 1997.
So I was 30. Let's see, 33 now. Let's see. No, it was 43.
Um, you know, I had had quite a bit of material, so, and.
Three of my first book, C.
C that's right. Uh, so,
so each book kind of ends with a question of sorts or in my mind anyway,
that's the next book. And it's also a strategy when you're cutting.
Cause I always, I usually write too much material then I think, Oh,
I really don't want to give this up.
And I could talk myself into doing that by saying, I'll put it in the next book.
And then it shortens that book. So you don't feel like you've wasted your time,
but person by temperament, I feel like if I don't write pretty much every day,
it's like, if I don't go work out, if I don't ride my bike, I feel anxious.
Like I really need to write, I just have kind of a need for it.
And I know other people like Isaac Asimov is like that way.
Apparently Stephen King is like that. They just got to crank out the material.
Cause it feels good. It's just sort of what I do. You know,
like an artist paints, I write whatever. Um, and so I, I find a lot of,
you know, it's not a chore. I don't have, you know, writer's block per se.
I have time block. I just have, you know,
I just need more time because I enjoy it.
W one of the things that I really like that you do,
and it's not just in this book, it's,
it's in really all of your books or at least the last few since I've known you
is you give credit to a lot of the other current thinkers that are talking about
these things. And I think that's a,
that's actually a kind of unique trait because a lot of people want to sort of
sit there and make it seem like they came up with all of this.
But even I was looking at the,
I was looking at the blurbs in the back of the book and, and actually I, it's a,
it's a Rubin report reunion over here. Cause you've got Steven Pinker,
Jordan Peterson, Dean Strawson, Nick Christakis, Amy Tewa and Jonathan Haidt.
And these people that you reference, they've all been on the show, which,
which is nice. But, but that is one of the things that I like about this book,
because you reference a lot of these people and their ideas as sort of the
starting point for starting point or maybe mid point for how you think about
things.
Were you always that way that you would sort of hear somebody and kind of mirror
what you think against them?
Yeah. To a certain extent. Um, uh,
but as a writer and as a consumer of many other books,
I can see some authors are more generous about crediting,
where their ideas came from and, and sort of tracking for the reader,
how they came up with their thesis of the book or whatever, others, not so much,
I'm not going to name any names, but some people do write in a way,
like they just came out of this whole cloth. It just popped into my brain,
like the muses, you know, and that no ideas happen like that.
We all build on each other. Everybody does. And you know,
in scholarly papers you have to cite just tons and tons and tons of references.
Uh, you know,
and that's why sometimes the reference says sections are as long as the papers
themselves. So, um, you know, so I always felt like, well,
I want to be generous. And, and just sort of honest and say,
here's where I came up with these ideas because of these three authors or these
16 sources or whatever. Anyway.
So I just got in the habit of doing that just from training, uh, as a,
as experimental psychologist initially, and then a historian of science,
you just have to do that. But just personally, I feel, you know,
when I see that someone like Richard Dawkins is very generous about that.
He's his, his Steve Pinker, you know,
deciding where all these ideas come from quoting other people. And it's like,
I like that. I'm gonna, I wanna make sure I do that too.
Yeah.
So one other thing before we dive specifically into the topics in the book,
because you have now been on the Rubin report at least six times,
which places you at number one, which I'm sure despite your,
despite your rather lofty resume,
I'm sure that's clearly at the top of the list. Uh, but for,
for somebody that's watching this right now that just doesn't know anything
about you, can you just give me a two or three minute sort of recap on,
on how you kind of became the skeptic skeptic?
Yeah, well, you know, my day job is publishing skeptic magazine and,
and directing the skeptic society,
which is a five Oh one C3 non-profit science education organization.
I got interested in the topics,
which is pretty much any of the super interesting topics related to science and
religion and spirituality and cults and free will and determinism and God,
you know,
pretty much all the great topics I'm interested in really goes back to being in
college. And I was a born again, Christian. I was, uh,
in 1971 when I was in 11th grade, uh,
I had two close friends who were interested in converting me.
I didn't even know what that meant really. And, uh, uh, uh, George had Frank,
so George had a really cute sister and invited me to church. So I thought, well,
okay, here's my chance. But then when I got to the church, it was,
it was Presbyterian church in Glendale, California,
and that the minister was unbelievably, uh,
dynamic and just really motivating. And, and at the end he said,
come on up and you can accept these as the whole thing will happen right here.
And I'm like, all right, I'm going. So I went home,
I didn't even know I was doing really, but I did it. And then, you know,
took it pretty seriously. And then I went to Pepperdine university, um,
which is a church of Christ school and very conservative. And, you know,
Gerald Ford came to speak and Edward teller came and gave his mutual assured
destruction, speech, and everyone was dying, Rand, Atlas, shrugged,
and all that, you know, pretty much what you'd expect.
But then when I went to graduate school,
I kind of drifted away from being religious, mainly for two reasons,
one, you know, studying social psychology, anthropology, sociology, you know,
I could see that other people's religious belief systems are very much context
dependent, geographically dependent. Right. So had I been born in India,
I very likely would not be Christian. Had I been born, you know,
10,000 years ago that there would be no Christians. Right. So, uh, you know,
it seemed to me that that, that doesn't make it wrong,
but it makes it more likely to,
to be mythically true as our friend Joel Peterson would say,
not empirically true. We're going to get into that. Yeah. So,
um, but, but then also the problem of evil that the Odyssey, what, you know,
why good bad things happen to good people. And, and I'm not talking about,
you know, like a human volition of homicide or war or something like that,
but just like innocent children, dying of leukemia, or, you know,
thousands of children dying from starvation every year and so on. It's like,
why would a good God allow that to happen?
I note there's tons of books and papers by theists and theologians about this.
But to me, they've never squared that circle. They've never solved that problem.
Other than like rabbi Kushner's famous book when bad things happen to good
people, he, his conclusion was, God simply can't do anything about it.
He's just not, um, he's not omniscient. I mean, he's not Omni omnipotent.
He may know everything, but he can't stop evil. Okay. So that's,
that's one solution. Another one is, well, they're just as bad. And, uh,
and that's the simpler solution too.
And that explains a lot because if you understand the laws of physics and say
the second law of thermodynamics, entropy, just happens, you know, just,
it's mostly just random. And the, you know,
there's very little directionality to why things happen other than just
statistical probabilities. And that's it, there's nothing to explain. Um,
you know, like the Corona virus, what's the cause, you know, 500 years ago,
it would have been, you know, well,
women have been cavorting with demons in the middle of the night or the Jews
poisoned the well, or, you know,
some of these kind of crazy supernatural paranormal and erases bigoted
targeting of peoples to explain, well, we don't do that anymore,
except for the 5g craziness. Uh, because you know,
we live in an age of science and, and hopefully we've moved past that. So to me,
um, once I left the church and really religion, um, I,
I was still interested in answering the big questions like,
well then where did the universe came from? If there was no, God,
what's the origins of morality. What about consciousness?
And why is the universe tuned the way it is,
where do all this diversity of life come from? And, uh, you know,
all the great questions from a secular perspective.
So in trying to answer it myself, I thought, well, I want to write,
this is what I'm going to write about from a skeptical perspective.
So my little niche, my lane, as they say is, you know,
kind of on the margins of science, the pseudoscience and the paranormal,
the supernatural,
the sort of controversial stuff that most mainstream scientists don't deal with.
That's my lane. And from there,
I can tackle the great questions just for my particular perspective.
And for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia instead of
nonstop yelling, checkout our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist there, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.